it is now my sincere uh pleasure and
honor to introduce
hillsdale college president dr larry
yarn who doesn't need an introduction
from a personal uh standpoint i
mentioned our family was at convocation
and we actually were supposed to have it
outside on a blessed day like this but
then the storms came we had to run into
the gym so it was just you can imagine
people moving all day and being sweaty
and smelly going into the gym
it was it was it was a moment to
remember but i went through the same
feelings and leslie went through the
same emotions that you went through and
that happened to be dr aaron's first
convocation so all this was new to the
stolberg family college sending off her
first child going to a place called
hillsdale college and they have a new
president
and what you heard this evening and were
touched on this evening by dr aaron's
talk at the convocation you get a sense
for the man who is leading this
university and what we saw then and what
we see now we are so blessed to have dr
aaron leading this fine institution this
hillsdale family
he is a great steward he cares deeply
about what we're about
he's got a vision that goes well beyond
hillsdale college in terms of sustaining
that and we're thankful for that
he's got an impeccable background and
you've heard some of that but
this is a man of character
and after looking and observing and
being in awe of seeing what he's done to
this institution we are very very
blessed to have a man of character leave
this university ladies and gentlemen dr
larry yarn
how you feeling
we're okay how many moms cried
how many how many dads
yeah
it's a more honest group this year
i think our character standard is going
up
i i uh i am a very privileged person in
my life and one of them is for somebody
like todd to say what he just said about
me
because there isn't a better person
anywhere than he
and i'm not a better person than he is
uh
he i just get to do this
he's a
wonderful man thank you
um
i i i want to
give you more assurance and some things
that might help you
be part of our family
i mean a working part
i'm going to say that we have something
vital to do
something that has to do with the
well-being of your children as a start
and as a finish
but also with the well-being of
everybody the well-being of our country
the doctrines on which our college was
begun and the practices that it has and
had
have been thought for
nearly 3 000 years now to be the key
to good living on earth
and they're almost everywhere discarded
and we have to sustain them against
an enormous world that has moved in
another direction
almost anywhere else you would have sent
you could have sent your child to
college
they would not take the core curriculum
that we put everybody through including
ourselves
and i will tell you it's torture as well
as joy
it's not easy
it changes the experience everything
about the place is different
because of things like that
and if you wonder sometimes uh
i don't know pete roscoe might be in the
room but uh
see here wave your hand up congressman
if you're here
no his kid's not a freshman so he didn't
come
we have a congressman roscoe also
congressman aiken pete roscomm has
become a friend of mine his daughter is
a sophomore here now
and he's you know real smart
and a congressman
and
and he's a he's a really good guy
really good guy
and
we're gonna we're opening up this kirby
center
and every time i see him he says send me
a book to read
or tell me the name and i'll get it and
i i never saw it i've sent him a lot of
books now
he will say i've given him to 30 people
in congress now that book was so great
then he said to me last time we met he
won't mind me telling you
he said i'm intimidated by plato and
aristotle
and i said yeah they're intimidating
but you just start out and read them you
know and try to see what they say
and he said i need help and i said okay
i'm gonna help you
because uh in our new kirby center we're
going to have a murphy bed in it up
there on the top floor and i'm going to
stay in that when i'm when i'm in town
and
um
we could you know at night
we could read aristotle and plato
and he just he said you know i live when
i'm in town my wife and i live two
blocks away
can we really do that
i'll bring other people he said
and do you see why that's important
it's important because
you cannot understand
the basic terms in the american
declaration of independence
anybody hear what i said so far
i was responding to the point from todd
that i've got to be the handsomest guy
in
town i actually made the mistake of
asking people at my table what i should
say
and mary ewers of course gave me like
400 things to say
and i wrote them down but i'm not going
to say them because todd already said
them
mary's got one thing on her mind
leslie miller said that i'm supposed to
say that she's a charming and attractive
lady
and that she's starting some kind of
scholarship fund and she wants you to
help her
so you can help her stand up so they can
see you
see she just said i was joking
which is proof positive that she did in
fact say that
and speaking of charming an attractive
lady that's my wife penny right there
and every term it happens two or three
times that some kid gets a little low
and gets to balling
and mostly they go to diane phillip or
aaron peterson diane's better because
she's more comfortable than aaron
they're the deans of students but but
sometimes they show up in my house and
they're typically find penny there and i
will tell you just can't be in a better
place because she's very nice person
so
i was saying about this
thing you know we live in this country
where
everything is threatened every
fundamental thing in our country
we live in a time
when there is legislation to define
the family
on the presumption that you could do
that
you see
but the family is here in this room
your kids are 18.
if you were some other kind of being you
would not know who they are
and yet it is much more important to you
what i do for them than anything else on
earth
and the reason you're here in such
numbers and attending so closely to what
i say
is because it has the good at stake of
the being most precious to you
now if you live in a time when things
like that are debated and become
subjects of legislation
then that means the fundamentals are at
stake and they need to be recovered
and so i want you to know that our
partnership can only work if we have
common purposes
and if you understand those purposes
we can cooperate
and that's what we're going to do
i i'll tell you the magic of that i it's
just nothing like it
i i have a principle of management today
it's my favorite thing to say about it
it's a two-step process
hire good people
then take credit
and you know
like the most the parents organization
they're just crazy you know they
sometimes think i'm a traitor to the
college because i don't love it enough
or praise it highly enough they're so
partisan about it right
well part of that's them of course
that's them the college is pretty good
and your kid's likely to have a really
good experience here and if it's not
we're going to do everything human
possible to fix it
that's one reason why they will
but it has to do with mary too and john
for whom she works
and and the point is magic happens if
you treat the world like that because
we're doing this kirby center and that's
an idea of mine from forever ago a
graduate school too just for about 20
students
i've been working on stuff like that for
20 years thinking that that would be a
great thing to do
but it wasn't my idea to teach the
chamber chorus to sing patriotic and
holy songs
jim holloman did that
and he's wonderful at it i know nick
sings for him and
it wasn't my idea for seven well sam
connect you know a year ago you got to
go see if you get next time
how are you going to see his painting
i think the k'nex live here in town
i think you should go over there and
ring their doorbell
maybe they sent it off to washington
today i'm afraid they did
he's painted this 12 foot long
9 foot high
of the signing of the
constitution and i've been studying that
thing forever
it'll knock you down
it'll make you cry when you look at it
it's so beautiful
and you see
he did that
each person brings what he's got
called to do it not by me
by the call of the good
and the true and the beautiful
the love you have for your child is a
reflection of that call
and if we cooperate on that basis
we can build
and these
are the two things that we are about
here
and they are written in the founding
document of the college in its first
sentence and they have been the aim and
practice of this college for 170 years
and while we
who are pledged to it live
we will not abandon this calling and it
is
to build the best and the cleanest and
the finest liberal arts college on the
face of the earth
and by that means
to save the greatest political nation in
history
if those are our aims
it will require
all of us
and we are going to work together to do
that
and i want you to know something else we
are not going to work together
for four years
we're going to work together
while we live and breathe
get ready
we're going to become parents alongside
you to your children
they're going to call us when they think
about getting married
they're going to wonder what job is the
best
some of them will ask me personally to
deploy them as if they were soldiers in
an army
and they will do that because i will
have treated them like equals
i will have expected the very best of
them i if they ask me a question about
the finances or anything else of the
college i will answer it
and they will they will walk around here
feeling like they own the place
because they do but ownership carries
responsibility
i'll tell you a financial fact
we get our money from three places
from gifts from uh
endowment and from you
if you pay full tuition which only about
10 of you do you pay for about half of
it
now that's a good thing and if i had
more money i wouldn't charge you that
much
i would only charge you as much as it
takes to make sure that you and your
child are urgently committed to this job
it is in fact is not mainly your money
that we're after
now endowment has been up and down and
rocky lately and our endowment has done
better than anybody's just about
but
how's that going
pretty good you know
in the 20 years before i came here the
dow jones industrial average went from
about 900 to about 11 000.
and in the 10 years since i've been here
it's gone from ten thousand to ten
thousand
gifts are uh
really important here
and uh
last year the year before last we set a
record about 37 or 8 000. i can remember
the number people gave us money last
year 116 000 people gave us money
and by the way
i tell them
that your kids
are great and they are going to save the
world
and the people say wow
i want to be part of that
and i say the same thing on campus like
right now for example
and once you know that what you know is
from the pan point of view
we are partners right now
but i want you to understand that is not
the most significant aspect of our
partnership
we have taken a pledge together
we are together now to raise these kids
do not think that we can get separated
from each other we are not going to let
that happen
in rare cases your kid will have some
kind of discipline problem that becomes
kind of serious
there were
15 such cases last year
if that happens your first instinct must
be to be on our side
you can find out if we're right we'll
tell you everything
but the idea is
we are here to do something together
and we are going to do it together
relentlessly until we are successful
and because we do it in the way that we
do it
these kids are going to become marvels
and the world is going to shake and get
better because of it
or else then we're going to redouble our
efforts and double them again after that
if we must
i want you to know that is the spirit of
the place
we did not come here to lose and we did
not come here to quit
thank you
ladies and gentlemen as you leave this
evening there are tables upstairs like i
mentioned there's also coffee to go
now if you'd like to take a tour of
campus they're going to be organizing at
uh 6 30 i believe right mary
and meeting right upstairs so if you'd
like to take a tour of campus as you are
if you haven't already seen it by moving
your son or daughter here and throw take
advantage of that thank you
god bless you and godspeed
you